I bet you've seen this drop stitch pattern
in ready to wear sweaters.
If you're like me,
you've wondered how it's done.
The thought of counting and transferring
stitches and reforming stitches,
it's really overwhelming.
But put your ribber to work and make
yourself a cheat sheet
and you'll be amazed at how much fun this
is to knit on any machine with a ribber.
I'm thinking of using it as a substitute
for the front edges of our
Elongated Stitches Cardigan.
It would also be beautiful
for an all all-overover sweater design.
Let's get started.
Use a fine yarn for this pattern.
I found that I really
struggled with thicker yarn.
Plan for a multiple of 4 plus 3
stitches.
This will give you columns of three purl
stitches on each side
of your knitted piece.
We don't want to be working the drop
stitches right along the edges.
Because this is a double bed stitch
pattern, we'll be using both beds
and we'll need to hang the Ribber comb
at some point.
Here is the easiest way I found.
Raise your Ribber, pitch H and put
the needles from both beds into work.
And knit one row with ravle cord across all
of the needles. So you get your zigzag row in there.
Insert the teeth of the comb
in the ribber loops.
Uncouple the ribber and pass it across,
so the ribber stitchers drop off.
If you've inserted the comb correctly,
the comb will hang in those ribber stitches and
provide nice even weight on your work.
With the cast on comb in place,
use any cast on that you like to start
your knitting. The cast on must be
stretchy for this stitch pattern.
I tried to loose crochet cast on over
the needles on the main bed,
but honestly, I found this to be
a bit tight in my finished piece.
In the future,
I think I'll cast on with waste yarn and ravel
cord and then finish the edge by hand.
Did I mention that the cast
on needs to be really stretchy?
OK, one way or another,
we've got some stitches on the needles
with the main yarn on the main bed,
we've knit one row.
Next we'll set up the Ribber
needle arrangement.
No, don't go all cross-eyed on me.
The goal here is to get our beds set up
in this needle arrangement.
The main bed with 3 needles and work.
1 needle out of work all the way across
the bed. And on the ribber will have
the two needles on either side of these
and B needles in working position
and two needles out of work between them.
Accomplish this however you like,
but here's a suggestion.
Raise your ribber and swing to P.
This will ailign the needles
directly across from each other.
Transfer every 4th stitch
down to the ribber.
Now, having the ribber set in this
position makes this transfer
easier, goes directly down.
Next, we want 2stitches stiches on the ribber,
so we need to create a new stitch
by picking up the butt of one
of the stitches on the main bed
and transferring it down to the ribber.
Swing your ribber to H
to make things easier.
At this point, your needle
bed should look like this.
Keep the Ribber set to H
for the whole pattern.
Identify your A and B needles and mark
your needle bed or create a cheat sheet.
Keep in mind that we're going to be
dropping stitches, alternately in sets.
Can we finally start knitting?
The first set is the A set.
Put the empty out of work needles
identified as A into working position.
Knit 10 rows.
And then drop those A stitches and put
the A needles into out of work position.
The second set or the B set,
you can put the emptied out of work
needles identified as B in working
position knit 10 rows.
Drop the B stitches and put the B
needles in out of work position.
Will be repeating these two steps, these A
and B steps for the length of the piece.
When you're done knitting the length
of your piece, transfer all the ribber
stitches up to the main bed.
Now both of those Ribber stitches are
going to double up and fill
the emptied A and B needles.
Knit one row with the very loosest
tension and blooselyindoff loosley.
Did I mention that the cast
on in the Bindoff must be loose?
Now for the fun part.
Drop all those stitches and form
the pattern.
There's something quite satisfying
about deliberately dropping stitches.
Block your piece to show off the pattern.
This stitch pattern looks great on both
sides, opening lots
of design possibilities.
Please give it a try and add
a designer touch to your next project.